well it's been 13 years since the first
avatar was released and if you're like
me you've spent all that time learning
everything there is to know about
Pandora is sex like within the V
intertwined their hair braids sure James
Cameron who brought us such hits as
Titanic the Terminator and who can
forget Piranha 2 the spawning has
returned to this alien planet with even
more water than my third class cabin all
jokes aside Avatar the way of water adds
to the rich Laura Pandora and in this
video we'll be taking a look at some of
the film's biggest questions reveals and
what it could mean for Avatar 3. so
sahelu to your elu I cringed a bit
saying that because we have a lot to
cover it's been 15 years since we last
saw our favorite paraplegic Marine Jake
Sully at the end of the first film he
had his Consciousness transferred
permanently to his Avatar and if you pay
close attention you'll notice the first
and last shots of both films are nearly
identical they both start with sprawling
vistas of the forest and end with
close-ups of Jake ready to start a new
chapter of his life but a lot has
changed in the 15 years since a Jake and
the navi fought off the rapacious
resource development Administration the
company hell-bent on procure during
unobtainium Humanity's most coveted
resource fundamental in creating energy
but as we'll find out in the way of
water there's a new resource in town
that makes unobtainium pale in
comparison this new substance drilled
from the frontal lobe of highly
intelligent creatures known as the
Tolkien is known as emrita which
translates from Sanskrit literally
meaning immortality and no wonder
because this Elixir stops aging my mom
is gonna be really excited but as we get
further along in this video we'll
discuss how this substance combined with
the impending destruction of Earth sets
up an even larger battle for Avatar 3.
Jake's been busy in those 15 years
getting freaky with his soulmate natiri
they have three biological children the
eldest natam younger brother Loach and
little tuktiri or took for short and if
that wasn't enough they've adopted two
others the first is Miles spider Socorro
a human child who was left orphaned on
Pandora being too young to make the
journey back to Earth via cryosleep he
was taken in by the sullies and it makes
for an excellent Tarzan origin story
what makes spider even spicier is his
parentage his biological father is
Avatar one's a main villain miles
courage his mother Paz zakoro who we
meet in the Avatar graphic novel The
High Ground was killed while piloting a
scorpion during the assault on the Tree
of Souls leaving him orphaned the other
adopted child and far more mysterious of
the two is Kiri who is birthed from Dr
Grace Augustine's brain dead Avatar we
never find out who kiri's real father is
although some of the characters joke
Norman Grace's avatars got it on but I'm
inclined to think there is something
more spiritual and Supernatural at play
here if you listen closely during the
scene where they talk about kiri's
father you can hear a recording of Dr
Grace in the background talk about her
theories on the planet's biology her
lines here are directly taken from the
first movie in which she theorizes
everything on Pandora is connected
combined find this with a recurring
belief among the navi that when one life
ends another begins and that energy as
we know it is simply transferred and
borrowed from one another including Life
Energy it's entirely possible that
during Jake's attempt to save Grace at
the end of the first movie her energy
wasn't transferred into the Avatar
rather the Avatar's womb this would mean
that kiri's birth was that of for lack
of a better word Immaculate Conception
by AWA or the Navy's God and I'm
inclined to believe this Theory
considering the supernatural type of
powers Kiri seems to possess first the
seeds of the Sacred tree seem to be
drawn to her in the first movie nitiri
teaches us that these seeds are a good
sign it's actually what stops her from
killing Jake the first time she
discovers him and the first time we see
Kiri she's almost in this trance-like
state on the ground as if communing with
the Earth and of course she has these
weird abilities that we've never seen
any of the other Navi do there's even a
scene where she tells Jake that she can
hear a walk so it's clear that we're
just scratching the surface of kiri's
abilities and I think she'll be the most
important character when it comes to an
eventual confrontation with the humans
clearly a fully armed human Force could
Wipe Out the navi but maybe the navi can
stand a chance if they have someone who
can harness the power of AWA now things
seem to be going just swell for the
sullies until the RDA rears its ugly
head seems as though their brutal defeat
after the failed assault on the Tree of
Souls wasn't going to keep them at Bay
for long returning with them is Colonel
Miles quartz now in Navi form an avatar
was created just for him and instilled
with his personality and memories think
of it as a very expensive backup copy
it's a win-win for the RDA and quartz
the company gets these unavi soldiers
instilled with the training of Marines
to infiltrate the rebels while quartz
gets a second chance at life and the
ability to seek out his revenge quartz
is under the command of General Ardmore
she isn't in the film much but I suspect
she'll play a larger role role as the
battle between Navi and the humans
intensifies things have gotten much
worse for Earth since we last checked in
and general Ardmore tells us that Earth
will soon be uninhabitable and thus
Pandora must be taken over so they can
rebuild Anew getting in the way of this
plan is Jake Sully in the omotakaya clan
the forest tribe we met in the first
film they've been raiding key supply
lines and really putting a damper on the
rda's foothold on the planet any attempt
to breach their stronghold in the sky is
met with Fierce resistance in the Tree
of Souls unique flux Vortex makes it
impossible for the rda's advanced
instruments to give them a battlefield
Advantage thus Avatar quartz is tasked
with killing Jake Sully Commando style
and getting him out of the pitcher the
sullies however decide to leave their
Clan when spider is captured and Jake
finds out he's being hunted by Quartz he
gives up his status as Olo aikatan or
clan leader he knows it's better to
leave the clan rather than stay and put
them in danger it's not that he's a
coward he just knows that this is best
for his people over the course of his
journey he'll learn that running isn't
the answer he must stay and fight which
is essentially what he says in the
film's final moments this journey leads
him to AWA atlu a met Kane a village on
one of Pandora's thousands of islands
this clan refers to themselves as Reef
people and share some distinct
differences from their Oma Takaya
counterparts such as webbed hands and
more robust tales for swimming even
though he knows the danger clan leader
tonawari takes them in after they invoke
oturu a plea for sanctuary and just like
Jake had to grow accustomed to a new
life among the alma Takaya in Avatar his
whole family must adjust to Life By the
Sea this includes how to swim taming
creatures known as ilu and dodging
glances by the navi equivalent of a Bond
girl the RDA tracks down Jake to the sea
but rather than go Island to Island
burning everything in their path quartz
decides to lure Jake out by slaughtering
these giant whale-like creatures known
as tolkun as we learned from Dr Garvin
these creatures are insanely smart and
have a strong bond with the reef people
every year they migrate and meet up with
various members of the clan in which
they share stories songs and life thus
killing a tolkun is seen by the Met
kaina as a murdering one of their own
and a declaration of war a particular
interest is Loach and the bond he makes
with a tolkun named payakan the two are
similar in that they are outcasts loock
always tries to help and prove himself
as a warrior but seems to always screw
it up in the eyes of Jake he feels like
a disappointment that's why it's so
heartwarming when in the end he's the
one who saves his father Jake will say
the iconic Navi line I see you to him to
acknowledge this payakan was Outcast for
committing murder something that is
forbidden among the Tolkien but later
we'll learn that he was simply trying to
defend his family from vicious Tolkien
Hunters like scoresby who if you haven't
seen the movie has the coolest death
with his arm getting chopped off just
like he was responsible for chopping off
Perkins in it's when Loach goes to warn
pack and that the RDA is on the way he
Soraya and took are captured by courage
now quartz has the ultimate leverage in
getting Jake to hand himself in and when
it seems like warch has won the day a
pack and free Willies into their boat
this allows the Met kaina to launch an
attack in an attempt to save his
siblings lox older brother natam is
mortally shot it's the film's big death
and motivates Jake and iteri to finish
courage once and for all they know he'll
continue to hunt them until he's dead
the Final Act of the film focuses on a
one-on-one battle between Jake and Court
in which this absolutely massive RDA
ship slowly capsizes like The Poseidon
Adventure in The Fray nitiri tries to
save took but gets sucked into the
bowels of the ship and only by using
kiri's ability to channel these glowing
sea creatures are they rescued and
brought to safety Jake and quartz duke
it out with Jake put in Quartz in his
sleeper hold but both men seemingly
drown but don't hold your breath Jake is
saved by Loach and in a far more
interesting turn of events spider ends
up saving quartz but why would he do
that especially considering a few
moments later when they make it to the
surface spider decides not to go back
with him rather remain with his real
family the sullies first of all there
must have been a lot going through this
kid's head this is his dad and his only
living blood and by saving him he
actually proves to his father he's not
like him he's doing the very opposite
thing courage would have done second a
few scenes earlier spider had a knife
pulled on him by his very own adoptive
mother when she tries to use this as
leverage against quarridge quartz
actually ends up doing what she asks
proving he has some feelings towards his
son this event has major ramifications
for the next film first we never see
spider tell the others that he let
quartz go for all they know quartz is
dead will he tell them or will it be
something that blows up in his face in
the next film second if My adoptive
mother held a knife in my throat and
threatened to kill me you'd bet I'd lose
all trust in her natieri mentions
throughout the film that spider should
be with his own kind so the
psychological effect all this is going
to have on him will be huge it feels
like they're setting him up to be a
villain but my guess is that in the end
he'll do the right thing netam has given
a traditional metcane a funeral where
his body returns to the Sea it is said
that we come from the sea and after we
die that is where we go so it's only
fitting we see him return there netium
even takes the fetal position further
signifying this connection between life
and death natiri adds a bead to this
device known as a song chord which acts
as a family or Clan's history each bead
telling a significant moment or event in
time it's accompanied by a song sung by
natiri once at the beginning of the film
when her kids are introduced and again
at the end when they mourn the loss of
their child but on Pandora the dead are
never fully gone by accessing the
underwater tree at The Cove of the
ancestors Sully and Gary can visit him
as part of their memory but where does
this leave us going forward the sullies
are officially welcomed into the metcana
clan and Jake says that he is done with
running he will fight and no doubt there
will be serious repercussions for the
navi after their Victory we know from
General Ardmore that Humanity needs
Pandora to survive which will
undoubtedly culminate in an all-out war
between all the tribes of Pandora and
the RDA we barely scratched the surface
when it comes to all the various tribes
of Pandora and you can bet Jake will
take up the mantle as leader to unite
them all Avatar 3 which is still yet to
be titled is set for a 2024 release so
if you excuse me I have to be put into
cryosleep until then thanks for watching
everyone what did you think of Avatar
the way of water I want to hear your
thoughts below make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
is sexual equipment and it's why their
hair braids sure